that's the moment the Kardashians first
found out about Jordan woods and Tristan
Thompson's alleged hookup a four-way
phone call between Kim Khloe Kourtney
and Kylie Jenner this all went down back
in February but is just now playing out
on Keeping Up with the Kardashians with
Khloe having just spoken directly with
Jordan why did Jordan say she had to
call you back now we don't know how or
really if Khloe ever got but here's what
Jordan shared on read.table talk after
the incident on the way out he did kiss
me man we mean by kiss it's just no
passion no nothing on the way up you
just kissed me and like a tongue kiss
like a peck on the lips
Peck love like a no it was like a kiss
on the lips but no tongue kiss no making
out God and nothing you know everyone
has their truth in their story and so
you just go with go with it everyone has
the right to speak their truth et spoke
with Jordan just days ago after this
teaser dropped I'm just like what were
you thinking I knew who he was I never
in a million years
that's who she was it just sucks it has
to be so public how do you feel that
you're being portrayed in this hopefully
um like myself and you know the real me
will shine and hopefully everyone finds
peace and their truth I feel like you've
moved on like this is like you are not
going backwards what life moves on money
doesn't stop world doesn't stop and
hopefully everyone is just you know
going forward it seems safe to say
Jordan will have to deal with the drama
moving forward - it plays out as part of
the Keeping Up with the Kardashians
season finale and will continue into the
next we're on to shooting season 17 so
you'll see that and I think one of the
things that has made the success of the
show is that we are you know show those
vulnerabilities and we're also
transparent and you do see how it
actually unfolded and what happened
because everybody thinks they know the
whole story and they don't so I think
that's the interesting thing is just
watching how we all handle you know
these situations
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]